I'm Jan Ken guard CEO of king-size Bo's
incorporated and welcome to my Bo
Kingdom we're in the joy business we
make special occasions special I have to
say that our most popular bow is our
signature monarch fold the red and
silver one
the Lexus commercials that we've had the
privilege of doing for the last eight
years has really drawn attention to the
multi loop bows we're the only ones in
the United States who actually make
those bows we make them out of a variety
of fabrics and textures and those are
the ones that people are most interested
in there's a whole bow language that
most people don't speak but there are
definitely differences of opinions about
how many loops how long the tails should
be and whether there's a V cut or an
angled cut we are pleased to be in every
showroom from Ferrari to the many to the
Ford to BMW now we've found that
customers really expect to keep the bow
when they buy the car they want to drive
away with the bow you'd be surprised
where people put bows it's not just on
top of a car any place that you want to
say look at me look at me it can be on a
bicycle or a surfboard or skis on a gate
on the top of your house at a pinnacle
once you put a bow on it it's a present
[Music]
we're driving out to Long Island today
because we found out there's a man out
there who legally changed his name to
Santa Claus so yeah we're gonna go
interview Santa it turns out this Santa
is not so traditional
I Drive the black Dodge pickup truck
with vanity plates oh yes I have vanity
plates this is Santa's sleigh before he
was Santa
he was Frank I was born in Brooklyn but
we lived here on Long Island I have been
married 23 years now so how do you tell
your wife that you're changing your name
to Santa Claus she said as long as I
don't have to change my name
go right ahead Santa has been Santa for
almost two decades
and he's good at it I'm probably on and
this is not an exaggeration
thousands of refrigerators he's got the
laugh you know that's that's my Santa
land
the suit I designed my suit but here are
some other things about Santa that might
surprise you I have three tattoos on me
of me
I'm very into zombies I love barbecue I
have a smoker they can fit 150 pounds of
meat in he's got this tiki hut and
above-ground saltwater pool in his
backyard yes I'm that extreme when it
comes to my idea of relaxation so
there's a little Frank left in there but
no question he's fully committed to
being Santa I want to look like the poem
says I'm the most loved person on the
planet
we totally met Santa we have six weeks
to harvest a million kisses and that
means you got to move fast
[Music]
as soon as harvest starts it's time to
call in the Calvary
[Music]
the state Oregon is the largest supplier
of Christmas trees in the country here
in Oregon Christmas trees outnumber
people twelve to one holiday tree farms
is one of the largest Christmas tree
farms in the world we have about 8
thousand acres of actively growing trees
the only thing we grow is Christmas
trees we sell a million Christmas trees
a year but you got to remember we
harvest them in a very short period of
time we can cut and process a Christmas
tree and have it loaded on a truck in
less than 24 hours the steps in
harvesting a Christmas tree start with
cutting each tree individually with the
chainsaw slingers will pile the trees
and rig them for extraction next we
bring a helicopter and fly them into
waiting trucks each tree is shaken
bailed loaded and then it's on its way
to market
[Music]
although they started using helicopters
in the early 1980s
throw a lot faster than you gain it by
hand
the helicopter can harvest met a
thousand trees an hour we normally run
between five or six helicopters every
day sunup to sundown
[Music]
we've been taking care of these trees
ever since they were very tiny seedlings
an average noble fir is about eight
years old when harvested and six to
seven feet tall harvest is my favorite
time in the year that's when we get to
see the payoff four six seven eight
years worth of work for every tree that
we harvest we plant another tree in its
place so when we harvest a million trees
we plant over a million trees the next
spring
it never stops so what do I think of
fake trees is a Christmas tree farmer
throwing competition obviously we're all
street farmers I was saying about fake
trees nine years in the house and nine
million years in landfill they cannot be
recycled it's Christmas keep it
[Music]
everybody knows jolly old Saint Nick
he's the bearer of good tidings and
cheer well in Austria he's not alone and
we don't mean Rudolph
[Music]
these are Krampus a sort of monster that
travels with Saint Nick they scare away
bad spirits and look for naughty kids to
punish making Christmas a whole lot
scarier people in Europe have been
welcoming the Christmas season by
dressing his Krampus for hundreds of
years
I am Ralph Hetzel and I am the oldest
Krampus here in town out Market and the
5th of December we came to the child's
in their homes and the good one gets
some sweets from the Nicolo and the
pepped ones get hit with the width from
the Krampus then we go from house to
house for five six hours and after we
recently to all the children in out mark
there's a little run with all Krampus
together the story of Saint Nick and
Krampus goes back to 375 ad and the
costumes and traditions haven't changed
much since the dress from the Krampus is
made of wool from the Sheep the masks
are made of wood and so when you're
walking around to all the children to
the houses for some hours you really
will get sweat it's like a workout it's
funny to go into the houses from the
people the reaction is different some
childs are not scared come to you and
grab to affair in other ones screaming
and running away the Krampus is a good
reason to change their mind from the
children try to be good for the next
year I'm dressed as Krampus this year
the 15-time very lucky to go every year
I'm very proud to be a part of this
whole tradition
[Music]
when you find a tree that has an apple
and just discovering new varieties it's
just I mean I live for that
I'm Annie Brennan my wife and I we
around our town and we forage for wild
apples and we make it into a series of
ciders based on where the apples are
located you sell at the Gramercy Tavern
yeah yeah Gramercy Tavern which I've
only not once
I know it's famous and especially their
wine menu is somewhat famous having
cider made from wild Farge fruit is
really unusual something that can only
be done in very small amounts what comes
out of the bottle is really special we
go out into the woods we go to places
where apples are not at all influenced
by human cultivation we're searching the
woods and sometimes it's difficult to
find the trees man if the light doesn't
hit the silver and the trunk just right
you may not even know it's an apple tree
you're in luck when you find not just
one or two but a whole forest of trees
which sometimes does exist
[Music]
what I love is discovering varieties
that are just so peculiar you would
never find them in a grocery store the
other day we found an apple that has red
flesh so you bite into it and it just
looks like a pomegranate they're telling
us process
takes about four hours to grind and
press enough juice to fill a barrel
think of those barrels as bears its
hibernating nine months after you
collected the apples that's when it's
ready
you
[Music]